[Music]
uber is put a pause in its self-driving
car program while it investigates a
crash involving one of its driverless
vehicles a self-driving / car flipped on
its side after the driver of another car
failed to yield and hit it Mireya
Villarreal is in Tempe Arizona at the
intersection where this crash happened a
a good morning good morning this is
where the accident happened the uber car
was driving down this road right here
when another vehicle took a left in
front of it hitting it police say the
uber car was following the law and they
cited the other driver nevertheless uber
says they are putting a halt to their
self-driving program you're looking at
the latest corporate setback for uber
and its ambitious pilot program to
launch a fleet of driverless cars
nationwide the uber car on its side was
in self-driving mode during the
collision with two operators in the
front seats and no one riding in the
back and so uber as a result of this
accident said they're pulling all of
their self-driving vehicles off the road
despite the fact that authorities in
Tempe say that it was the human driven
vehicles fault and it just didn't yield
to it that the uber vehicle that means a
halt to self-driving programs in
California and Pennsylvania as well as
Arizona just this month
uber was reportedly given the green
light to resume its California program
after one of its self-driving cars was
caught running a red light in December
this is just the latest in a series of
high-profile corporate setbacks for uber
CEO Travis kalanick apologized after a
rant to an uber driver was caught on
video President Jeff Jones resigned a
week ago saying ubers approach to
leadership was inconsistent with his own
and now kolonics former girlfriend Gabby
halts Worth says she was recently
pressured to lie about going to an
escort bar in South Korea with five uber
executives in 2014 she says one of them
feared the incident would be discovered
by the press that executive Emil Michael
said in a statement that he did call
Holt's worth but that her recollection
of this conversation was different from
mine and I'm very sorry if the purpose
of my
call was misunderstood uber says the
incident was reported to human resources
it's hard to gauge just how much these
the sort of string of scandals recently
have affected its business and they have
to be concerned about how customers feel
about them every time they get in one of
these vehicles uber says that this is
just a pause for their self-driving
program meanwhile the company is waiting
on the results of an internal
investigation into whether an uber
executive engaged in sexual harassment
while others did nothing about it
Margaret
Maria thank you